y dejemos que ellos decidan cómo debemos
vivir nuestras vidas quieren decirles
cuando trabajar cuando sus hijos pueden
ir a la escuela quieren ponerles
demasiados impuestos y enviarles quieren
decirles qué tipo de auto pueden
conducir qué fuentes de información son
creíbles e incluso cuentos trabajador
cuántas hamburguesas pueden comerse
quieren desfinanciar a la policía y
quitarles su derecho a la segunda
enmienda quieren salud gratis para los
ilegales y sin ofrecer protección para
nada para los no nacidos quieren dejar
llenar la corte suprema con liberales y
quieren hacer todo esto haciendo que el
pantano como tal de washington dc y sea
el estado 51 con dos senadores más no
podemos cambiar el daño que ellos han
generado por eso los demócratas han
pasado una semana diciéndonos quién es
joe boyd él no lo que pretende hacer
me siento inmensamente
orgulloso del trabajo que hemos hecho en
el senado hemos sido un muro en contra
de la agenda de nancy pelosi como el
presidente son no seremos intimidados
por los intentos de los medios para
destruirlos las instituciones hablaremos
en nombre de millones de estadounidenses
cuyas historias no son contadas en los
periódicos cuyas luchas son igualmente
reales apoyaremos a las familias
mientras derrotamos al coronavirus y
haremos que la economía sea la envidia
del mundo lo que es en juego nunca ha
sido más alto
por eso les pido que apoyen a los
candidatos al senado alrededor del país
y regresamos a mi amigo el presidente de
la nación